[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link thanks for joining us for this
ear biscuit at the round table of dim
lighting this week can you sense our
guests here in our midst
silently waiting to be introduced yeah
yeah well there's a cuz I'm one of them
yeah I'm the other one it's just us this
week it's a it's another digital respite
from interviewing anyone besides
ourselves that's right your guests are
us threatened link you can you can get
away with this did I seem apologetic I'm
you know I'm not apologizing to you
loyal listeners I'm just trying to be
creative and telling you that we're it
this is awesome
but you can get away with this when when
you there's two of you if you interview
yourself as an individual then that
seems pompous separate self-absorbed
double definition especially if you're
asking the questions and then answering
them but we're not above trying that I'm
not gonna say it's it's not gonna come
to that but not today cuz today we are
going to we've got some of your
questions I think a few and then it
we've structured this episode to be more
of a reminiscing episode based on the
fact that a milestone is approaching is
that time of year again the summer so
you know the funny thing is is a lot of
times people you know you say things
like summer's here because you've done
something like your school's out or
whatever and then there's somebody's
like it's technically not summer yet the
summer solstice is not until Gen 21st or
whatever that's what it is this year and
I've been in you know I actually found
myself looking that up a second ago to
figure out home witness summer you know
summer is when school gets out it
traditionally whether you're in school
or not even if you're in year around
school okay this summer solstice thing
is overrated that happens halfway
through summer vacation and can I can I
take a second just to say take any
seconds never you won't never stop
learning I mean just because school gets
out or you're not in school anymore
or your brain is filled to capacity
never stop learning you know it hurts my
heart to hear you say that
how did you stopped learning me a break
did somebody tell you they stopped
learning that's what they were saying
just now the voices
oh the voices in your head you didn't
hear him no okay so this is what we've
decided to do we're gonna reminisce over
our summer jobs summer experiences when
it relates to occupational job the
street well you know I gotta say we have
a great job now I wouldn't trade it for
anything love what we do but it's
definitely you know summer rolls around
and what is it's just more the same I
mean we just keep on trucking
we keep making YouTube videos we keep
doing ear biscuits we don't have the
on-and-off-again schedule that you have
you know before you become an adult and
it's just there was just something about
that schedule that you had you you had
all these markers besides just a
birthday every single year to mark your
aging and make sure there were things
happening with your body that may have
embarrassed you a little bit and your
voice was changing and cracking and
those kinds of things there was all
kinds of physical signs that you were
changing but you had like a new grade
right you're like oh I'm in ninth grade
now I'm in high school new experience
and then in between each year you had
summer vacation and then at some point
somebody made the decision that oh you
just can't be a kid anymore you got to
go get a job you got to make some money
now luckily for me it wasn't like I was
I was being sent out to make money for
the family I know a lot of people
legitimately you turned like 12 and
they're like you got to bring home the
bacon you know mm-hmm if for me it was
just you've got to save up for a
Nintendo game personally it was a very
selfish pursuit when I first decided I'm
gonna do this summer pay for the gas for
your car type of a scenario yeah but I
mean I job was pre driving though so it
was oh yeah and yeah I I'm almost sure
yours was well if you're talking about
mowing lawns yeah
was my first job which was a summer job
but it kind of it you know it went into
the spring and went into the fall so I
don't I don't call that technically a
summer job but I was definitely an I had
an entrepreneurial streak there and it
and it moved it about the pace of a
snapper ride riding lawn mower well
that's gonna mean because our mean boy
52 asked on Twitter is lawn mowing a
good job for a first job when I lutely
link absolutely I mean there's inherent
hazards I mean there's a moving blade
you're heaven sakes so you shouldn't be
too young you got to know which side of
the lawnmower to sit on not the bottom
side so you got to you got to be a
certain age and say yeah my my Papa
Lincoln he got he got me lawns around
his neighborhood to mow him again he
negotiated the price and everything for
thank you swim along but I I took his
snapper lawn mower wrote it across the
street and I would cut Miss Alice's lawn
and then I would cut where we're talking
about how much port for a lawn $15 that
was pretty good back in those yes yeah
like I said I mean when the chief of
police negotiates your lawn mowing rate
he was charitable I'm sure the shocking
heat surely you weren't doing that good
of a job I was I was I was immaculate at
this thing man that the lawns were
immaculate I was immaculate everything
was whack I mean I remember when my dad
just tried to pass off mowing our lawn
to me and my brother you know my brother
was older so he was the first one to
take over the job from my dad but I
remember my dad out there with me with a
push mower we didn't have a riding
lawnmower
we had a push mower and he was had a
small long he was trying to show me how
to figure out where to mow next he's
like okay I'll see I mowed right here
and now I'm gonna mow the next strip and
I couldn't see the strip I couldn't see
where the grass had been mowed he got so
mad at me said you can't see where the
grass has been mowed you know and it's
just like I think about how frustrated
he was with me and then and it helped it
helps me these days as I relate to my
kids because I think we just can't see
the kids they just don't see things like
where the grass has been mowed even
though it seems so obvious to us is that
why you were held back a grade because
you couldn't see where like all right
caught big
I was held back for height actually no I
was put forth I skipped a grade because
of height not because of academic
performance okay so the lies cancel
themselves out right you neither went
back or forwards in grades but yeah I
mean I would I my business expanded
quickly
I had to dry this is before I have my
driver's license I drove that lawnmower
across Main Street Lillington to get to
lawns on the other side of town I
remember seeing you from time to time
most people would load the lawn mower up
on the back of a truck and drive it to
the places not I mean the lawn mower is
a form of transportation take it so I'm
I'm going across like a a production
yeah big in it I was at our stoplight on
a lawnmower and everybody 12 years old
well yeah I mean this is it's Lillington
North Carolina though it's not the rules
are different at least at the time and
like I said the Chief of Police
negotiated all of these heels for me he
didn't give you a police escort did he
no he didn't but I did have a siren on
that I did not my first job I didn't get
paid to mow the lawn from my from my
family I just did that on my own but my
first paid job was for Hartman and
Hartman Chemical Company number Hartman
Hartman yeah HNH
Jerry harm Jerry Harmons company yeah
and outside of Buies Creek North
Carolina is a clandestine operation like
he had a big warehouse behind his house
right now you know it wasn't behind his
houses helipad it was on the way to
Benson it was past coats on 27 on the
way to Benson and he just had a big
warehouse and it was H and H he was him
and his brother but never saw his
brother it was just him and and and some
other dude and then who wasn't his
brother and then me for a few weeks this
job didn't last long it was just like an
introduction to what a job could be my
mom dropped me off there because I think
I was 14 but what what did you do
well a teenage products was and maybe to
this day was known for their air
fresheners and when I say air fresheners
I mean like a bottle with a little
with some air freshener liquid in it and
then a rope wick
you know those old-school type air
fresheners that you find in like the
Shelf of a elementary school in like
1978 yeah and it's like all hardened and
you know what is this yeah all it is is
there some perfume inside of a bottle
like a little almost like a medicine
bottle a little brown bottle and then
there's this rope wick that goes into
the thing through some paper and then
the liquid goes up the wick in it then
it permeates permeating permeates into
the air did did you mix the liquids - no
no I had no contact with the liquids I
was a wick man I was the wick man I had
to cut the rope and fold it and stick it
into these paper tops and then pour the
liquid in there no no I I was too young
I didn't get the liquid there no no
Rhett doesn't get to touch the liquid
refuse a wick man he gets to touch the
rope and the paper and you do this like
eight hours a day you twisting wicks
cutting WIC it's not even a twist it's
just a it's a cut in a fold all right to
this day I am really good at cutting
equal sized pieces of rope if you ever
need that if there's a need around here
you know give me 14 - inch long pieces
of rope I'll be back in 90 seconds and
I'll have them and they'll all be the
same same length and it but they won't
smell good because I was a wick man
because you can't touch the liquids but
I'll this was the kind of job that I
lost heart really quickly early on every
day and I was that a pun because it was
hard man and Hartman I would I do a few
and then Jerry would come back there and
I need catch me just sort of daydreaming
I mean lots of Daedric like staring at
the wall yeah that was a daydreamer
buddy and when y'all when you give a
fourteen-year-old the wit man job I mean
you wouldn't expect too much right so no
but come back there and yell at you he'd
be like I read some wicks brother how
you you've only you know you've only
done 17 huh well just you know we're
gonna need we're gonna need a couple
hundred more today so did he fire you is
that
I'm hearing no it was a temporary
position I think I was actually raising
money for like a trip or something like
when we went to Trinidad or something it
really could have been it could have
been related the money kind of went to
charity uh well I mean I used it for
like a trip you know so okay I had a
good time but anyway yeah that was
that's the first actual work I ever did
for money now you talk about staring at
the wall one of my first jobs I became
known as the kid with the brain farts
that we didn't call it spacing out my I
worked for my uncle actually my my dad's
side of the family for one summer well
they always were farmers and then one
summer my dad worked with them and that
meant that I also worked with them at
farming tobacco okay that's a real job
now I'm talking and we called it Barney
tobacco because the process is there's
people who pick the bottom at
appropriate times you you end up picking
all the leaves off the tobacco stocks
but you do it over time when they're
ready start at the bottom the bigger
ones bla bla bla bla it's important to
set the stage for people where we grew
up North Carolina in rural North
Carolina tobacco is the cash crop in
it's in it's everywhere I mean on our
way from from my house driving to high
school you know was like a 10 mile trip
and you would pass 20 large fields with
nothing but tobacco in them nothing but
tobacco now that's not the case it's
going back home they've been replaced
with soybeans and other things but that
was the deal that was North Carolina so
their tobacco fields everywhere right
and I would I would drive over there but
the crack of dawn be like 5:30 in the
morning cuz it got really hot and you
can work in the heat of the day in these
tobacco fields but there would be a
group of people that would pick the
tobacco leaves throw them on a trailer
they bring the trailer around to the
barn and then I would be at the barn my
uncle would be supervising my cousin
would be there
Ashley Jonathan my half-brother he was
there it was like a family affair and
then a bunch of employees too will be at
the barn and you would grab big pieces
of big groups of these tobacco leaves
and you stack them in this apparatus
that would like a rack a metal rack put
them rack together and then pick this
very heavy rack up I would say the you
had to pick up the rack would like a a
crane type apparatus like a small
electric operated crane I'd say it
weighs 500 pounds one of these things
pretty dangerous in your held well I was
16 because I would drive I would drive
there and we would put the you know
you'd put the tobacco in the racks and
then you pick up the rack with the thing
and two people would feed it on to the
shelf and it was then you would slide
the rack Shh
push it all the way to the back of the
barn which is basically a metal box that
had a fan at the back and it would
slowly cook the tobacco over time it
would cure the tobacco so you load it
all a tobacco and I'm making my beef
jerky but it's a psycho yeah you would
curate it but it goes in green it comes
out brown and cured ready for cigarettes
and then you can put it in some cigs but
it was just so repetitive and you would
be waiting around for your particular
place okay once this is stacked I'm
gonna help you pick this up so you have
certain points in the process where you
would engage and then the rest of the
time my brain would disengage so I had
these extended brain farts there would
be no smell but it would be this is look
on my face of total stupidity that my
uncle Johnny just I said I he's having a
brain fart again and I would wake up and
everyone would be laughing and then I
would pick up something and move it
because it was just so mine what were
you thinking about those days I mean I
don't remember but anything but barn and
tobacco
I mean anything to get out of there
mentally and you didn't I mean what did
you think of when you stared at the wall
in the wick Factory you know all kinds
of things man ideas I was thinking about
that screenplay that we were trying to
write gutless wonders you were probably
thinking about the same thing you just
don't remember and girlfriends
potentially you're thinking about Anna
yeah it might have been a Sarah John
phase Oh think about Sir John huh yeah I
really get that picking picking tobacco
and thinking about Sir John but it was
just a mindless type thing that I became
known as mr. brain fart but and then one
day I got tobacco poisoning if the
tobacco is wet in it and it comes into
contact with your skin skin for a
prolonged period the nicotine and I
don't know what else from the tobacco
starts to soak in through your you know
you know your skin and I was I felt
deathly sick for about a week I couldn't
get out of bed you're kidding no how
come I don't remember this tobacco
sickness it's basically like you
vomiting if you had to just smoked a
bunch of cigarettes yeah having never
smoked like my body smoked six packs a
day you see you smoked cigarettes the
way a frog would smoke cigarette right
through the skin right it was vomit now
frogs do tobacco they just hold next to
a tobacco leaf they do tobacco I mean
that was a that was a tough job but I
think it's you know you know you got to
take part in like a cultural moment in
history yeah it is pretty cool to know
in which tobacco was being grown as a
huge cash crop in North Carolina being
made into cigarettes that everyone
around us was smoking wasn't that by
that point people had a lot of people
had stopped smoking just falling out of
oak a little bit uh and they were
beginning to send a lot of it over to
China where everybody was smoking in
China that's what a lot of the farmers
were doing but it's just interesting
that we talk in nineteen ninety-four
it's just sounds archaic it's like yeah
I worked in tobacco fields I'll never
forget I mean you had to invent things
to do in order to occupy yourself and so
whenever we would take a break my cousin
Keith who was a lot older big guy big
beard big belly big everything he only
wore shorts and like Teva sandals and
I'm very for pickin toboggan he made fun
of me for being a soccer player oh yeah
you're a dork he was um Bruce he was a
football player like big like linebacker
type dude he always make fun of me and
he didn't call me brain fart he just
called me soccer player and what he was
a it wasn't more great it wouldn't call
you soccer boy or anything not that I
recall
you know soccer player but he was like
and one day he was like man you think
you need endurance and speed to run
soccer man me being a linebacker I bet
you right now I could beat you in a
sprint to daddy's house uncle Ross his
dad its Keith still around somewhere
he's living but I'd I'd he's he's fine
he's not an ear biscuits listener he's
not at all thing you know it and I'm not
the competitive type and am i okay Annie
and so we go we go out to the dirt road
in front of the barn that we're burning
tobacco and he any scrapes is scrapes
his foot and draws a line start lines
like alright and he said he tells my
cousin Ashley he's like actually I want
you to count down from three and then
we're gonna go and I'm gonna show him
what's what and he's got on Tevas what
do you have on like Sambas tennis shoes
in shorts I mean it was it's 110 degrees
and I'm kind of nervous because like I
said I don't like to compete and like I
was literally if it wasn't so hot I
would have started sweating my armpit so
I was getting nervous I was like man I
guess I'm gonna try and it she's like
three two one and boom I just take off
like foam I'm just giving it all I got
and and I'm like I'm like Hussain buh
buh leaving the line and but after about
five Carl Lewis would've probably been
there right reference at the time five
five steps I'm like going full speed and
I just happen to look over my shoulder
you know and as I look over there keep
his taking his first step and he's
buried as Teva in the sand and fallen
flat on his face
like the first step he's the one who
issued the just stop that you could
recover from yeah mercy it's like that
MMA fight this going viral now where the
guy was beating him so bad that he just
tapped himself out out of out of pity
for the guy there's a video going around
that's what well that's what happens
anyway you know you had to do things to
invent ways to on brain fart yourself
did he ever did he ever say a word talk
about it didn't say a word
he never challenged you again didn't say
where when he got up there was
no conversation we just went back I mean
he was still a huge guy I wasn't gonna
make fun of it oh yeah he was like about
falling down I don't Caroline he shocked
a boy chocolate player over there you
worked one summer I had a pretty epic
job I did I had a couple of epic you
know heat of the South jobs pray tell
the summer after my sophomore year in
high school I started working for
Trent's dad
Frankie Hamilton construction mm-hmm and
you know Frankie was a man who owned a
lot of properties and was building a lot
of homes he's a construction business
and then he had a lot of rental
properties he's sort of a you know a
bigwig in the Lillington area and of
course we were good friends with his son
Trent one of our best friends did all
kinds of stuff with Trent what Trent was
cool cuz he had everything
oh you Frankie being so well off as a
home builder Trent was like the first
guy with like the souped-up computer
with the Internet he was got rooms he
was the only guy with this thing called
the Internet right in his own like
widescreen TV in his room in his own
bathroom in his own bedroom well and I
remember him saying you know I'm gonna
be working for my dad this summer and I
was thinking this seems like a good deal
you got you know Trent working for his
dad you know he's not gonna make him do
that much I'm in on this he's probably
gonna pay yes great because he's got all
this money so yeah I'm in on that and
then I show up my first day and I'm
ready you know we're gonna we're gonna
build things we're gonna change the
world and I won't do nothing and get
paid you know I say so what what what's
my job and they say you're going to be
the guy who goes to our homes that we
just finished building and you're gonna
clean out the crawl space so let me just
paint a picture here like literally the
space that you have to crawl in under a
house yes it's crawl space yes so in
North Carolina very few people have
basements and I don't know what it's
like where you come from but in North
Carolina and most of the South you have
the foundation of your house
and you've got this two to four-foot
area underneath the house right now as
the house is being built the
construction workers usually just throw
whatever it is that they have on their
person when they finish their meal from
McDonald's or they finish their Pepsi
bottle with a bunch of child juice in it
that's tobacco juice they just throw it
into the foundation because they know
that some dillweed named Rhett is going
to be personally responsible for picking
up every single piece of trash and then
putting plastic down underneath the
whole house it's a confounding is just a
convenient trash receptacle I mean they
they wouldn't like make to write in
there anything I smelled urine from time
to time I did but I got to tell you if I
was already six foot five at the time so
I you know I'm a little over six six now
six six and a half I was already six
five by the time I was 16 years old that
this is a large person to be going up
under houses and I and they were like
you got to watch for snakes under there
because this makes the black snakes and
the copperheads will get up under there
you know never saw a snake but spent the
summer squeezing around in this cave
alike place underneath houses totally
dirty at the end of the day is one of
those days where every single day I came
home I had those dirt boogers you know
what I'm saying you've been does buggers
he just been next to this dirt all day I
would get all this nasty trash all the
stuff that the construction workers are
just thrown into the foundation I would
package package it up and put it into
the convenient dumpster that was still
on the site that they could have been
using the whole time but they didn't Oh
and then I would roll out the plastic
was bent that summer Trent was off it
would doing stuff on the rental
properties so that summer we didn't
spend a lot of time together okay that
was that was a difficult that was a
difficult job but the next summer rolls
around and I'm like okay I'm gonna go
back and work for Frankie I
I don't all the details but I know that
I had worked it out with Trent that I
wasn't going to do that same job and in
transit no no you know what we're doing
this summer me and you and mr. Fred are
building a house I'm like what he says
yeah me and you to seventeen year olds
and mr. Fred a 65 year old man are built
the three of us are framing a home he
was like yeah okay so out there in
Lillington there was above your paygrade
what you think I had barely swung a
hammer and so the I'm not it almost
seems like I'm making this up but I'm
not making it up so we show up and
there's a foundation and this is a like
a ranch-style home a two-bedroom smaller
home mm-hmm and kind of about like that
the size of the house that you grew up
in in in Buies Creek over there so like
you know that's our own carport size
home and he says okay here's I've got
the blueprints so this is how I don't
know how home building works now but the
way it works
you never even build with Legos as a kid
know why I did a little bit take her
toys yeah that kind of thing mr. Fred
says all right here are the blueprints
there's the wood let's go and we look at
the blueprints and we start building the
walls he's like here's how you build a
wall you take you put a 2x4 on the
ground and then you nail it together and
then you do this and you do this and and
all right now this lifts it up and now
I'm gonna nail it into the foundation
and the whole summer we just every day
we just showed up at this site and at
what point did it all fall in on itself
well there was one moment where we got
to a place where the blueprints became
became a factor when we got to a closet
and I was like walk-in closet became a
broom closet I was like I don't know
what we did wrong but this closet is
about 12 inches deep
yeah they're a decorative door one of
the bedrooms ended up with a very
shallow closet
and you know I think that's just par for
the course it's something had to give it
in literally the closet Gabe at one
point we got to at the end of the room
and we had put it all together and it's
like after that you're like well I guess
it's just gonna be they're gonna have to
have some they're gonna put the shirts
sideways hanging up the shirts aside six
of them and I don't know if mr. federber
went back and kind of made up for that
but yeah we it was it was all the way to
Western Harnett on the road that your
your mom lives on now 27 okay so use it
so you this house is still there oh yeah
I the house is someone is someone who's
using the closet right now
you know Kirsten that closet every day
and it sits out there and it was on a it
was a foundation out on some land that
someone had and there was a only thing I
remember is there's a fig tree and we
would eat the figs off of this fig tree
huh so if you live between Lillington
North Carolina and Western Hornet High
School on 27 and there's a fig tree in
your backyard and you have a one foot
deep Closet in one of the bedrooms in
your home I built that house I mean an
old man rep build your house and you'd
like to come hang out this Christmas
when he comes back on okay we underscore
al 457 asks did you or Rhett ever get
fired from a summer job no but I came
pretty close and this job that I had is
gonna sound like potentially a really
fun maybe one of the best summer jobs
yeah I'd like to have that job but I'll
tell you right now it turned out to be
one of the most difficult I'll just say
it worst jobs I've ever had and I worked
in tobacco for a summer in college I
spent one summer in Santa Cruz
California and I worked at the Santa
Cruz Beach Boardwalk as an amusement
park ride operator there were different
sections to the park and I got assigned
to a section that had some kiddie rides
and then it but it had a couple of those
spinning rides
and you could she had cups it was kind
of like teacup so they couldn't say that
because well teacups are patented Walt
Disney wouldn't like you know run him
out of business or something so every
day you would come in and you the
supervisor would assign me to my ride
are you gonna be on the ladybugs with
the four-year-olds and you're gonna be
on the imitation teacups spinny things
kind of like a spider spinning thing to
it
one memorable day I was assigned to this
spin ride and the way that it works is
you have to put your foot on a foot
pedal in order to prove to the ride that
there is an operator there and at that
point you can press the Go button and
the stop button safety mechanism right
they just don't want someone to press go
and then walk away
so you get a C on that but the the way
that you would stop it there actually
there wasn't a stop button you would
take your foot off of the thing and then
you take your foot off the pedal and it
would hat it would take a while for it
to come to rest because everything was
spinning so fast and so there was an art
to stopping the thing subject to people
looking like they were getting sick so
there's not a predetermined length of
ride there is a predetermined length of
ride but people are prone to get sick
because they're so dizzy and then you
have to try to make the ride as long as
possible but cut it short maybe to cut
it short if somebody's gonna vomit so
that that was interesting there was a
challenge involved in that because they
told you this on the like the
orientation no I learned this myself oh
really I learned it the hard way people
vomited on my ride and then you realize
I'm gonna start looking at these
people's faces whenever they come around
and when the face it turns blue and the
cheeks are getting big I better learn to
anticipate that to take my foot off of
the pedal it was enough time for it to
stop and so they can get off and vomit
in the bushes now did we when someone
vomited on the ride are you personally
responsible for cleaning it uppers or
like a dude the vomit man nope it was me
and they had installed us repository had
a rolled-up garden hose
so this dude is vomiting I can't stop
the ride people start vomiting you take
your foot off the pedal and it's still
spinning oh gosh and then when he gets
on somebody else they vomit no get the
movies at least this particular this
particular time just that one guy I
think a girl when it stops she got off a
ran and vomited in the bushes but you
know I have to say okay I turned
everyone waiting in line I'm like I'm
sorry this ride is now closed I put up
the side all the people in line go away
they don't want to get on the ride
anyway at this point and then I have to
get the garden hose and just start
hosing down everything hosing the vomit
off of everything
oh gosh and it just so happened that
there was a hotdog stand right next door
to my ride which is stupid they should
put that on the other side not only
because people were eating and get sick
but because the it turns out that the
diameter of the hotdog is slightly
larger than the diameter of the drain
holes in the bottom of the teacups hmm
hmm meaning I had to garden hose
everything out and then I was left with
just nice bite-sized chunks of hotdog
somebody swallowed a hotdog pretty
quickly I mean that's how you eat a
hotdog you just bite you bite a bite
it's Wallace Wallace while I do I don't
know what he did but I'm well trained I
mean I can eat hot dogs really quickly I
mean I was spraying the the water
pressure like I was really trying to get
it to go down in that drainage hole and
I couldn't get him to go through that I
had to scoop him out rubber glove I
don't recall that I don't think we had
rubber gloves did you have a special
surety sure I had a rubber glove I had
out on like a tropical theme shirt oh
well
scooping out with a glove I'll say I
just I have to have thought I had a
glove I have to think I had a claw
scooping out hot dog remnants now that's
bad and then the next day you get
assigned to the little ladybugs and
four-year-olds are peeing and you got to
use Windex and clean that oh this is not
a fun job so and then you're not talking
anybody people don't want to talk to you
I just want to get on the rides and so
it's kind of this I mean there's cute
girls at the theme parks
there was this one about it you got to
perk up a little bit I just I was I
guess I was in brain fart mode but I
would I was miserable I hate it I would
just stare off into the distance and one
day my supervisor comes up to me and
she's like are you okay I'm like yeah
she was like no what you seem like
something's wrong have you received
really bad news
it's something going on personally that
you don't want to tell me about like no
no and I didn't want to tell her that I
absolutely hate my job she was like well
it just seems to me that you absolutely
hate your job why don't you just go home
and I was like what she's like you know
why don't you just go home and I was
like well I live in North Carolina she's
I mean just no for the day so like I
left it way back to where I was saying
an hour it was like it was a walk of
shame I was kicked off of my ride and I
had to I I came to work the next day and
I was like I'll have a better attitude I
apologized and everything but that was
absolutely embarrassing like I did my
friend something they're like why you
why you off work so I got a bad attitude
I had a bad attitude I get kicked off of
my ride soccer ball about it but did
your attitude really improve it seems to
me you've just brushed off and just gone
right back to it for a couple of days I
had you know I've really tried every try
but I mean you you know a couple more
days of pee a couple more days of vomit
I mean it just wasn't for me well it you
know the people you want somebody who's
opera you're having a good time you know
everyone else is having a good time
that's the point we're so close to
people having a good time but that's the
art that's the art of being in the
amusement business you know when I went
to Disney World recently there was a guy
who was orienting everybody to one of
the things it was like the Haunted
Mansion or whatever and mmm I know that
he was saying exactly the same thing
that he's been saying all day but he was
fresh he seemed so into it and I was
like you know what I got made me feel
like he just said this just to us in
this group that's the kind of person you
want to run into not soccer boy
yeah I it's you know it's one of my
biggest regrets in life I mean it's you
know what you can protective you could
be operating a big-time roller coaster
at Disney World now if you had to just
follow through ya blew it
face perspective you know I I didn't
have I didn't have perspective okay and
it seems like the coolest job I could
have had I mean I could tell you about
some of the other ones but I think that
that is assuming that we are not going
to have summer jobs anymore I mean maybe
after retirement they'll be like I'm
gonna go like Fred I'm gonna go buy the
H & H and I'm gonna be like I hey WIC
man's back wit man's back the end strong
maybe there'll be something like that
but assuming that we're not gonna have
summer jobs again maybe many of you who
are out there listening maybe you're
about to start your summer job I think
the thing is is that it's what you make
it there's a 99.9% chance that the job
that you're about to go do this summer
will have absolutely nothing to do with
the job that you're going to do in your
life you know your career and it's going
to be the subject of stories maybe a
podcast that you that you have years
from now and do you have more oh yeah
give me another one yeah
well my point what are you want me to
say say the point to the end I thought
that was the point sure saves a point to
like teaser well I was gonna say real
quickly well come back because there's
another job that you had that you forgot
about okay that will come back too but
I'd say my first job where I was in the
corporate America so to speak even
though it wasn't really corporate it was
a government job was working for the
Department of Transportation oh yeah so
every summer while I was in school and
NC State University my summer job was to
work at the d-o-t so the Department of
Transportation you know it's a big
government organization in that every
state and in North Carolina there were a
number of divisions but I was in the
pavement management division is it
exciting as it sounds just by virtue of
being a civil engineering major well
actually what ended up happening as my
dad ran into the guy who was the head of
this division at some golfing event or
something and he was like oh yeah my
son's majoring in civil engineering was
like well tell them be done to apply for
a job but with us in our department we
have making dreams come true have a
number of students from NC State
University that come in and help us out
every summer and the pavement management
unit pavement management so what does
that mean well first I was hoping that
it meant I got to be the guy who held
the slow stop sign out on the street
because every time I see that guy I wish
I could I could do with his job just for
you know a summer I mean the guy he all
I got to do talk about brain farts I
mean this is a job where you you can't
you are very tempted to have brain farts
but brain farts could lead to people
dying head on collisions you know you if
you see they're slower stop and you
better know which one it is but it
wasn't an outside job I think I never
wore an orange vest I never wore a
hardhat it was an office job it was a
desk job in a cubicle and what the
pavement management division was
responsible for was determining which
sections of road throughout the state
needed maintenance of course it's
basically just determining priority of
roads right and so there's a few things
that contribute it to to priority how
many people travel in this road how bad
the conditions are really that's the
main two things right how bad is it and
how important is the road so I don't
know why this wasn't something that I
mean I'm sure today this is the kind of
thing that they just have the map of all
of North Carolina in a computer you
think but in 1998 I'm sure it wasn't a
computer somewhere but I never saw the
computer all I saw were these huge 3
foot by 4 foot maps of the entire state
now I'm not getting 3 feet by 4 feet
this is a large map that barely fits
onto a desk
yeah and it was a map that had been
printed on somewhere
but then what we were supposed to do is
we were getting updates to there would
be red lines on the maps of like new
roads that had come in like printed red
lines yeah no somebody had drawn like
these new roads in and I don't know if
these were then going to be incorporated
into like the new somewhere on a
computer it was being done it was being
updated like so many hand drew somebody
had come in and said like hey here's a
new road that's been plotted or built
and and of course there would be all the
other roads and then our job was just to
go to intersections and circle them and
then number them call them nodes so the
way that you reference any section of
road in North Carolina is you say it is
node 4 4 8 3 2 4 4 8 - that's a section
of road and so that's classified as a
section of road and then it's prioritize
so if you missed one did you have to go
back and erase all the nodes and then
renumber them for 4 8 3 4 4 8 4 it was
so it was so first of all it was the
most boring thing it was worse than
Wieck man it was worse than wicking the
the air fresheners and there were 13 of
us doing it all on one map no so I I do
think that a few of the people in our
division we're doing some other things
but most of us circling intersections
and writing a number yeah in elementary
story first of all I worked there for
three summers and I probably got through
four maps you're kidding me you know I
was doing the rest of the time talking
just [ __ ] just three briefs yes just
sitting there talking to these other guy
other people who were college students
were they cool people yeah that's not a
bad job then no I don't sound like a job
at all I made some good friends I was
like you were on a break but it just I
was I was struck you know ever since
this job I've had kind of an informed
opinion when I hear that not to get
political but when I hear that the
government is attacking a problem or is
trying to work on a problem mm-hmm I
always think
was it like the Department of
Transportation because I worked there
and it was the most inefficient
operation I've ever been involved with I
mean what did you know your supervisor
was like hey suckle some knows yo this
supervisor would sleep really under her
desk I'm not kidding
really I don't know how often this
happened but there was a rumor going
around and it had been confirmed by
several of the people that I work with
that occasionally the door would close
and they would be like so you never saw
when we we know but I knew her well
enough to know that this isn't it was
not unexpected behavior apparently when
the door was closed and it was quiet in
there and the light was off it meant
that she was sleeping under the desk
they said one time we went in there and
she's like she was hiding no she's just
sleeping yeah she's laying down on the
floor I mean she's in a kind of a small
office and you can gotta kind of get
under the desk there and sleep so this
is there was a pervasive attitude kind
of from the top down of a lackadaisical
let's make this a break air and no one
ever really came to check and see what
we were doing is there a really pretty
girl that worked there I remember that's
all you told me about was it was like a
hot girl circling nodes mm-hmm you know
I'm sure yeah I mean there was a couple
of girls that I was you know I like to
talk to I like to bring my map over next
to their map how's the baby how's that
no settling going but yeah it was it was
just I was amazed and I and I'll say
this too I'm probably I'm probably
getting people into trouble but this has
been um it has been 15 years ago so it's
probably all different people another
thing that happened was water under the
bridge to use a civil engineering
another thing that happened was as I
said okay we have this fleet of cars
crowned victorious by the way one of my
favorite vehicles of all time and you
know your typical government-issue car
that it's a lot of cop cars but it's
also just a lot of government cards
you'll see in North Carolina you see
these Navy Crown Victoria cars with
yellow tags you know that's like the
government issue car
well our division had a fleet of cars
and what they were used for is they
would send people out to different
places different intersections and you
know you count traffic that's how you
that you know that sounds like fun
that's a piece of data that goes into
the system that lets us know what road
needs to be worked on because if you're
like okay this certain section from node
X to node wide okay you're losing me did
you drive in the cream come Victoria I'm
just saying you people go out and count
traffic with little clickers did you do
that no I did not count traffic but what
they said is in order to justify us
keeping a certain number of crown vics
or Ford f-150 pickup trucks in our fleet
we have to log a certain number of miles
on vehicles please and so they were like
go out and drive around the Beltline
really so I would guess to Rack denial
of the odometer I would just go out I
would take the Ford f-150 or the Crown
Vic along with another guy and we would
just drive around the Beltline around
Raleigh just yeah again just shooting
the NASCAR race yeah really yeah just
driving I mean it's not it's not a bad
job I think that's a pretty good job
professional I was a professional driver
for the d-o-t your tax dollars at work I
was in a domitor spinner what what's the
job that you told me that I forgot about
chicken houses well I'm not I didn't
work in the chicken houses I've worked
at like uncle Johnny had some chicken
houses and I worked around there oh but
here's here's what it was but you told
me about the chicken pit oh yeah they
had I mean I was around them but the
tobacco fields were around there oh that
was a did that was causing keys in there
and he was you know he'd like to be mean
to the chickens that's as far as I'm
gonna go okay he thought it was funny
but it was cruel and it was I'd rather
not bring it up or continue to talk
about it but there were there was one
summer when I didn't work for my family
and I work for will Thomas's family oh
and they had a lot of pig houses
what are they called pig farm and it was
these big long you know barns full of
pigs and what I had heard I was I knew I
was assigned to work with him because
we'll was gone that summer so was like
hey can you do my job with my family
and make some scratch and so our first
day I went and met his his uh actually
his uncle's name was Keith different guy
pig farmer and I had heard that you know
they they they make the pigs they well
they don't make the pigs they inseminate
the pigs okay you for some reason you
have to do it for them yeah yeah you
have to like you have to take matters
into your own hands it early so to speak
and I was that's all I was thinking
about was okay if I work in this pig
farm I'm not gonna have to do this this
is gonna I can't do this about how am I
going to tell it wills uncle Keith that
I'm just I just can't I cannot do this I
can't I can't be here for this and I get
in private medium that I meet him that
day and big strapping man big beard and
he he comes out front he meets a really
nice guy he's like link thank you for
taking wills position here this summer
while he's away but I got to break it to
you we don't need you here at the pig
farm and my heart like leaps for joy
it's like I need you to go with my
brother to to secure lands for so that
the ATVs don't get on the Carolina power
and light property so for the for the
rest of the summer I wrote around and we
were drive for like four hours and I
would just fall asleep in the passenger
seat and we get out extended brain fart
with you know with this this cable
cabling that was about two inches in
diameter and we would cut it with
torches wrap it around trees where
people were taking four-wheelers into
the woods on a private land in order to
keep the ATVs and the four-wheelers out
of private property exciting stuff it
was it was uh it was riveting you ever
run into a full you know somebody on a
four-wheeler he wanted in no we didn't
have any altercations but we had to go
down one time and clean up all this
trash off of the land and someone had
dumped literally about overtime about
400 old
visions on private property I mean back
out there and you know in the in the
sticks
people would just make any old piece of
land a landfill oh yeah and seeping I
wanted to clean it up and the the the
glass on the front of these televisions
can get it as much as an like half inch
thick or more and but then they would
dump them out so it would be the
shattered glass that would be thick and
I had to pick it all up using like trash
picker uppers and just with my hands cut
my hands a lot right on that one but
that that was not a good job either oh
but you didn't but there's no like epic
I went to the emergency room I lost a
finger
no I as you can see I still have all my
fingers but I didn't have to mate pigs
artificially no yeah anything's better
but you know what happened there you
were originally slated to be the the man
they make the man handler but he saw it
my saw in your eyes was like I can't put
this do it put him out on the trail you
know there is one other job that is the
only job that I can think of on all of
our summer jobs that we actually did
together you think about the grok yeah
now that I so this was probably our
first job ever because this is basically
before we got summer jobs in the summer
we were on opposite ends of Buies Creek
we would ride our bikes to the middle of
town in Campbell University in the
middle of Buies Creek and there was a
little grocery store called the grok on
the edge of towns not there anymore
sense but but that was kind of our
halfway point roughly our meeting spot
when riding our bikes to meet up we'd
meet there we'd play pinball it was a
Gilligan's Island pinball machine there
and then we would we'd go on our summer
escapades out around Buies Creek for the
rest of the day but we got to know the
guy and here's a he was a very creepy
creepy dude ran the girl ran the croc
back then probably he's probably 40
years old and he's like hey boy you want
a job but he looked like a character off
of The Simpsons you know he had a hit
he's kind of swarthy yeah like a pirate
and and he actually did he sounded like
he wasn't from around there goes like
this was he like this I'm not from
around here I'm from The Simpsons
gharlane's would you like to you like to
make some scratches Krusty the Klown no
and he did say hey guys I'll uh I'll pay
you to sort baseball cards and I do
think this is pre H and H I think this
is this is the first job ever but this
was there's no contract and it was
probably a violation of child labor laws
because we were probably 12 13 years old
baseball cards were a big deal he would
they were on display out there and
people all the I guess high like grade
school and high school kids would come
in for like different camps at Campbell
and they would come over and buy
baseball cards but in order to know if
you had a whole set you had to you had
to order them by number to be able to
sell a complete set and that's what he
said do you want to order baseball cards
literally just take piles of baseball
cards and order them by number up and I
mean a set could have a hundred and
fifty cards and then you would start
over and build a new set so he could
sell it so I'll give you a dollar an
hour a dollar an hour each there was at
50 cents each it was a dollar and we
said yes we did it we like never told
our parents that we like hey that's what
we were doing and he put us in the back
room he said just go back here and it
would like he would throw all these
baseball cards it was like it was like
child labor type scenario yeah anyway we
totally illegal mean honestly spread all
these baseball cards now that I think
about it another think about it we we
could have been in danger you know we
didn't know adults knew where we were we
were just like this guy that we by
clearly Canadian from and play the
pinball machine in this little weird
grocery store he's got us in the back
room sorting baseball cards
I mean we weren't nothing never happened
no he never came back there I mean there
were some some magazines stuffed in the
in the pool table that gave us quite an
education on the human anatomy yeah that
seriously expanded our perspective
but other than that I mean it was hey
give me my dollar I'm a $5 and we all we
only did that for a four I'd say a
couple of weeks or so but you know
that's only time we ever worked together
until we've reunited yeah that was our
first answer but the entrepreneurial
spirit the seed was was planted at that
we could have been come expert baseball
cards husband say smugglers but sorters
but we moved on to other things now I
should say my dominant summer job I have
to tell this one you know just because
this is the one I did the most my dad he
did work on the tobacco farm that want
that one summer but for most of his life
even even now he is a house painter and
carpenter and tile artiste kind of a guy
he's got multiple employees working for
him now but for many summers I was
expected to be his right-hand man so I
was always painting with my dad and it
was always very frustrating because my
dad would do this thing where he
wouldn't he would give directives like a
mime like Enki it's like he would be
telling me to do something and then all
the sudden all the words would get
jumbled up and you psyched up and then
he would it wouldn't be English and he
would start pointing and gesturing and
expected me to understand I want you to
take this specific color mix it with
this specific color go up this ladder
and only paint the front of the trim
like he would communicate all of that
with Jessica with hand signals grunts in
grunts just because and I don't know why
and he I don't think he really realized
it was happening was he was it seemed
very obvious to him what he was
communicating and I would really very
frustrated okay and and so what has
happened is I now do this right all the
time not all the time no I would say
that it is not it is not uncommon
especially especially if there's
something physical like we're moving
something or building something and
there's like some sort of
and yeah and you're just like and you do
you do the same thing it's mind-blowing
yeah and it's extremely frustrating for
them mumbling grunting and moving of
hands and then extreme frustration when
I or anybody else who's in the room
doesn't know what you're talking about
and I won't you haven't said anything
but mentally have a hand water you
inherited that yeah I mean and I don't
think I learned it I do think it is a
genetic thing at a certain stress stores
probably but the you know the funny
thing I worked for him for all those
summers and it was fine except for the
Poynting and when you know I would
eventually figure it out and I would do
the right thing but when I was in let's
see after I was married there was there
was like this career transition thing
happening there was just one summer
where for a few months I wasn't working
as an engineer and eventually they hired
me back as a contractor kind of to like
bridge the gap between my like career
transition but there was a point there
where I called it my dad and I was like
dad I I just don't have anything dude
can I can I come back and help you and I
wasn't I wasn't a high school student I
wasn't a college student I was a grown
man with a wife and like I just left an
engineering job and I'm back working
with my dad
painting houses and he was he was doing
some more intricate tile work than so he
would teach me how to do the tile work
so I would go outside and cut the tiles
to fit and of course he would tell me
how to cut the tiles using only hand
gestures I mean he's not a mute he can
speak just like me just like normal but
whenever it gets really frustrating it
has to go to the hand signals and I
remember this one time you know being a
full adult if things got really
frustrating I would I went in the house
and I took him into the tile and and
he's like no no no I got it I really
need this corner cut off and in the
Poynting happens and then so I go back
out and I take a little bit more off and
then I go back in there and it's still
not right and by this time I've cut too
much off I gotta start over I go back
out for a third time and then I go back
in there and I don't remember what he
said that there
time it wasn't a hand signal but there
was something that was said and then I
just I had had it like I could not get
this piece of tile cut how he wanted it
no amount of hand signals or words could
help me understand what I needed to do
and I don't remember exactly what he
said but it was like the it was kind of
harsh and I I backed away slowly
basically ran outside and I was gonna
cut the tile again and I started crying
my dad I was a full-grown adult Oh
married made you cry and I I was so
frustrated that I was like crying in the
front yard of this house in Lillington
did you tell him I don't remember
exactly what happened it afterward but
it was that awkward moment of like I'm
so upset I'm crying and then I'm so
embarrassed I'm crying and then boy this
is funny and I was kind of laughing at
myself and then you know we we stopped
for a break and like we're eating our
oatmeal cookies and you know drinking
our Mountain Dew like we would like like
we always like painters do like painters
do and we did have a conversation about
it and cleared the air and it was it was
a good experience
yeah I need you to use your words it's
like well that's what we used to say we
say that to my children now use your
words it was just so frustrating in that
particular moment and I don't think I'm
certain that I contributed to the
frustration and probably deserve most
signal talkers talk trying to try to
communicate with each other it's
probably what you don't realize is that
you were also so you were like three
three minutes into a signal only
conversation there's not a whole lot
that can be communicated unless you
actually know American Sign Language or
any other sign language yes I mean
that's that's the last time I've that's
the last time I've cried I don't believe
that that's that's that's my defining
summer job moment yeah you can finish
what your application with your teasing
- well I was gonna say you know you're
doing this job if I could go if I if I
could go back and talk to my
self I would do anything differently I
think I probably would have like stood
up and questioned a few things in the
d-o-t that's it that's that's one thing
I might go back and do and be like well
should we be driving the cars around the
Beltline and maybe we should be working
more efficiently but you're doing
something like folding a rope and making
a wick or standing there waiting for
tobacco to be shipped to China or
whatever is gonna happen with it or or
cleaning up hot dog chunks I would just
say if there's any way at all possible
that you can just be engaged you know I
think the story here is that neither one
of we were just kind of along for the
ride right it was just like a brain fart
waiting to happen
you're like holding the brain fart
daydream waiting to happen one of the
things I'm trying to teach my kids now
is just I just remember how like not
present I was hmm and so I was just kind
of always off somewhere and just didn't
care about much stuff and maybe it's
just I think it's just something you
have to kind of come into but I'm just
trying to I'm trying to somehow impart
just be in the moment you know like if
you have an opportunity to do something
just do it and do it right and do it
well and take some pride in it because
you don't want to get sent home from the
boardwalk you know you don't want Jerry
Hartman to come in there and question
how many wicks you've been through or
you don't want to be brought to tears as
the 22 year old by your fault right and
if your cousin Keith challenges you to a
race
don't hesitate run the race and when he
falls down on his face after taking one
step don't turn around
keep going going keep running run to the
run to daddy's house and then the first
one back for lunch and then then point
and laugh at him I didn't say that I
kicked dirt in his face well maybe if
some dirt accidentally gets on his face
as you're running like Carl Lewis to
daddy's house so be it
I don't really know what the application
is
but it's just you know you know and if
an older swarthy gentleman asked you to
sort baseball cards for a dollar an hour
in the backroom of a creepy grocery
store say no or just at least say well
dollar fifty and don't look at the
magazines that are stuffed into the pool
table pockets stay away from those
mm-hmm no good can come from that
okay but a lot of good came from this
year biscuit I feel like I've
reconnected with my youth and with my
summertime sometimes some some
summertime feelings about getting a
summer job on the side now now that we
talked about this let's do it man I'll
uh I'll sort some cut baseball cards if
I had to go back and do one one of those
jobs I build another house I'd like to
go back and do that again I get the
closet right this time thanks for
hanging out with us in this ear biscuit
leave us of your view on the iTunes
that's helpful also hashtag ear biscuits
us and let us know what you think about
this particular episode tweeted us maybe
I'll talk about something else you want
us to talk about something else we'd be
glad to do that this one you know is
kind of reminiscing a little bit but if
there's just something you guys want to
know about there's something the
industry related or whatever we're
willing to talk about it and next week
we'll have another ear biscuit interview
just like we do every Friday thank you
for being a loyal listener
yeah with a person who is not us so is
there for that yeah listen to you next
week
or you to us you know I'm trying to say
[Music]
[Music]